what's my investment strategy so i got
an interesting question from one of my
youtube viewers why
zl91 who wrote in to say hello evan do
you have any financial plan or
investment if so can you share your
opinion sorry about my bad english i'm
from another country so this is an
interesting question i've never been
asked about my investment strategy and
uh i'd be happy to share it so
first of all i believe that the best
investment that you can get is in
yourself and i would bet on myself and
invest into myself and get a return on
that money faster than i would on any
other investment right if you're looking
at a stock that maybe earns seven
percent
a year i can get better than seven
percent by investing into myself so i i
always believe that and you should too
you should feel like money you put in
you'll get a better return invested in
yourself than into some stock or mutual
fund the next thing to think about is
the most important decision that you can
make with your investment plan with the
extra money you're looking at
is asset allocation okay a lot of
governments will help you give you an
incentive to put money away save for
retirement so if you have some kind of
retirement savings plan the most
important thing to think about is asset
allocation and that basically is how are
you going to split up your money what
percentage is going to go to stocks what
percentage is going to go to you know
real estate bonds
angel investments whatever it is with my
money i like looking at companies that i
can invest into where i like what
they're doing
and i like that i can add some value to
it so i feel like i can be a
contributing part of their company
i'm not a super active angel investor i
look for opportunities where i know the
entrepreneur and again i really like
them i like what they're doing i think i
can add some value to it if you're just
talking about investing money this is
something that i i used to be really
super passionate about i thought i was
going to be
a stock broker and help people with
their financial plans and what i was
passionate about when i was younger
until i realized that the whole industry
is a scam you look at the mutual fund
industry it's just one big scam
none of these guys beat the market on
average none of these guys beat the
index on average it doesn't happen maybe
one year yes but consistently nobody
beats the market on average
so if you don't do anything if you're
just gonna you know you're gonna invest
in stocks your best bet is honestly just
to invest in an index fund just invest
in the fund that that tracks the index
you're gonna make whatever the market
makes what i like to do is
i mix up my money between
companies that pay a dividend so safer
stocks that pay a nice dividend at least
four percent that i also see some upside
to i'm from canada and we have some
pretty big telcos and banks our banks
are pretty safe compared to most of the
banks in the world
and they pay nice dividends and so i'll
invest
a chunk of my money kind of my safe
retirement money into
those stocks and then i'll always have a
percentage
between uh 25 and 45
of my money will go into stocks that i
see an opportunity with so i call them
high flyer stocks
stocks where i see
i think that this company could really
take off i don't have insider
information on it obviously but i like
the company i might be a customer of it
i like where they're going i see a lot
of potential and so invest in those when
those do well i sell it off and then i
invest back into my safer stocks
and then find some other high profile or
high risk or high risk stock to invest
into that's what i'll do i don't know if
it's necessarily the best strategy for
you i don't own any
uh bonds gics mutual funds uh none of
the super safe stuff a lot of that is
part of my age too right i am how old am
i i'm 34. what year is it 2014 so i'm
34. i'm 34 in may so i'm 33 right now 34
in may
and
i can afford to be
riskier because i have a longer time
horizon so if you're a younger person it
makes sense to put more money into
stocks because on average it pays off
a greater return over the years but if
you know you need that money
soon or if you're retiring then it's a
lot riskier to go all into stocks so the
most important thing again that you need
to figure out is what your asset
allocation is what percentage goes to
stocks what percentage goes to bonds
what percentage goes to mutual funds
although i'd say avoid those because
it's a scam
and i would encourage you to read up on
this like it's great to go talk to
somebody and learn from a financial
advisor and you may end up working with
them but i wouldn't just give all my
money to somebody and say here go you
know make me rich it's not going to
happen you need to educate yourself just
like you would on your business educate
yourself on where you're putting your
money and you should be knowledgeable
that you know you're comfortable with
where your money's being spent and that
you're going to get a return that's uh
that's good for you so that's what i do
just i guess kind of touching on the
subject let me know what you guys think
give it a thumbs up if you like it you
have more questions from here you want
me to dig deeper on the topic leave it
in the comments below i'll make a video
response and you want to see more videos
like this click on my face to subscribe
to the channel thank you so much i'll
see you soon